oh on y va merci
oh regarde le petit canyon
juste derrière ouais c'est vraiment sympa
pour les arbres dans l'arrière
-cour fais juste une belle rotation lente autour de
la vitesse la plus douce possible
ouais c'est une bonne vitesse je pense
quel est votre sentiment
vous les gars  ouais c'est une bonne vitesse ouais
n'apportons pas de
vibrations ouais avec la basse vitesse
je pense que c'est probablement bien
même si
je peux éviter un peu mon virage ouais
bon c'est bon donc je peux passer de l'autre
côté
je suis désorienté
ces pompes
oh je vois l'autre maison là-bas maintenant c'est en
panne
nous allons juste faire un autre cercle
ouais
nous en ferons un autre plus large après celui-ci
et nous pourrions en faire un plus proche sur
celui-là avec la piscine je pense ouais d'accord
juste un  plus comme ça et puis euh
wow voilà c'est bien
comment le feu pourrait arriver ici
c'est drôle parce que comme certaines maisons sont
c'est un arbre
juste
ouais comme nous l'avons vu
je repense tous mes arbres sur ma
propriété
après hier ici la nuit dernière
c'était  bizarre rappelez-vous  on aurait dit
qu'ils avaient comme des décorations de Noël sur
eux
réservoir
ces deux
est
ouais
celui-ci est le meilleur à
droite
alors
oui j'aime le premier plan de ces
deux leurs maisons ouais le contraste là
-bas et puis hillary
ouais d'
accord
maintenant voyons comment je finis  ce genre de
genre glisser dans ce bloc ouais d'
accord
ce qui se passe tout le monde alors
viens haut pour moi
finis de tirer en premier d'accord
est-ce qu'il a juste une radio et il dit
maison ouais ce n'est pas juste
pour lui demander s'il ne dit pas à richard
veut  de savoir qu'il n'a
rien de mieux à faire d'
accord on finit ouais
et puis alors pause
c'est un gros bisou doux
garde la foi la
prochaine fois tu vas leur manquer
belles protections sur la piscine
ouais
je ne veux pas que ça arrive  pour moi,
jamais
vous n'imaginez
non
suivi de
merci
noueux
il y avait un chien qui marchait le long de
cette clôture arrière où elle reviendrait,
ce qui est un peu étrange, vous savez, d'
accord, vous le prenez juste dessus et je vais
juste en quelque sorte incliner vers le bas  dans la voiture
nous pouvons  fin sur ça peut-être
oh deux voitures dehors
oh tu as raison
wow
incroyable peut-être garder les gars non
on va en faire un autre elsa
quoi de neuf
wow
et ouais d'
accord bon
je
compte un peu sur toi pour me guider à
travers ça  chose
si gentille juste de tourner avec la rue à
droite ouais une fois que vous arrivez
devant cette maison de
l'autre rue il y a une camionnette blanche
dessus à droite
et trois des trois véhicules
d'affilée à
droite d'accord bien d'
accord il y en a un autre qui ralentit  un
peu d'
accord continuez il
y a notre pool
house c'est
tourné ouais
faites-le jusqu'à ce qu'il soit parfait ouais d'
accord j'ai fini par être un peu plus
direct, ce qui est un peu délicat pour nous
devrait être un autre ici le
dernier oh avons-nous pensé  c'était juste
un après le tournoi ouais oh d'accord
tu as raison je pensais qu'il y en avait un de
plus d'
accord
faisons une pause
un peu plus lentement
non il l'a ouais d'
accord maintenant je vais aller vers cet
arbre suivant d'
accord là  on y va
je veux en quelque sorte faire un panoramique sur un tout petit peu
c'est  bon
maintenant je peux m'attarder un peu
dessus en inclinant un peu au fur et à mesure qu'on passe
dessus ok ouais
on y va tu les verras surement
mieux ouais comme ça
mieux
ouais c'est juste sur le bord
ok
essayons de refaire sans  l'
ombre
je pense que nous sommes euh eh bien je veux dire est-ce que vous faites
exploser les gars pouvez-vous un tout petit peu oh
il y en a un autre oui
nous l'avons fait cette fois c'était bon
aller lentement
ombre embêtante
donc
donc nous avons fini par évidemment  une
sorte de vue de côté
mais je ne peux pas
je pense que ça marche ouais laisse juste
glisser ouais
ouais
je pense que nous pourrions essayer de savoir comment
tu as emménagé comme ça penses-tu que nous
pouvons essayer de faire un
plus serré
ce sera difficile mais oui nous pouvons
est-ce assez serré pour vous ouais un
peu plus lent peut-être
donc
alors
oh d'
accord
j'ai fini un peu trop vertical ici je
pense
qu'on y
va wow
ouais
mais ça ne l'a pas fait
nous en voulions plus ouais  c'est le dernier
ouais ouais d'accord emmène-moi dans la
rue un peu plus que d'accord
oh  merde
je contre ça on y va
on recommence ok ouais commençons
ouais
ouais tu ne voulais pas euh directement
dessus ou
euh voyons euh
peut-être un peu plus sur la rue
ok donc un peu à droite de chez toi
oui
juste  très tu sais presque sur le
trottoir
oh
alors
commence à me frapper dans le bras
la pression
ne gâche pas ça maintenant
et il y a de la lumière
ouais peut-être qu'on recommencera avec un peu
plus de lumière ouais exactement comme ça je viens de
finir ça  un ce n'est pas mal
tu vas dans cette direction bien d'accord
et il y a aussi une petite zone de
brûlure j'avais besoin de tourner dans cette direction d'
accord c'est bien d'
accord plus euh parce que euh
oh il y a un cheval là-bas qui tourne en
rond fou dans
l'autre sens  détendez-le
vraiment au milieu
euh
étrangers
sont-ils en train de regarder quelque chose là-bas
autre que nous
je ne peux pas voir
s'ils regardent vers le haut
wow il y a comme des enfants qui courent partout
c'est parfait
bien sûr
signale le cheval en cercles
il est au milieu  de l'h  ous il
n'a pas beaucoup d'espace
cool
oh
alors suivez vous pouvez glisser plus sur
la route et juste le prendre sur la route d'
accord
alors allez tout droit euh hors de la route alors
désolé les moteurs d'accord ouais
il n'y a plus hein
non d'accord arrête
ça tu vas juste te sentir mieux mais
veux-tu faire ça,
faisons-en un de plus d'accord, maintenant,
allons-y, sommes-nous bons ouais d'
accord, allons-y
alors
allons à l'
étranger
bon oh wow ouais
huh
oh
ça
oh bon d'
accord
je pense que c'était cool c'était cool d'accord d'
accord pouvez-vous faire de la statique s'il
vous plaît il y a quelque chose d'écrit sur la clôture
en rouge oh nous voulons avoir un gros plan de
ce truc de dieu aussi ouais  c'est une autre
chose, c'est probablement condamné
et ensuite nous ferons des statiques de chacun d'
accord
s'il vous plaît
combien de temps voulez-vous que ce soit un bon
mec 130. ok
savez-vous ce que nous avons
commencé à 20
personnes voyez-vous cette voiture elle
attend juste là
ça a l'air bien d'accord donc euh
mais
c'est incroyable comment le
comment  le mur s'est plié
oh
le début de la maison en fait sur
la gauche qui est resté totalement debout ouais on
dirait que le garage
et le palmier ont survécu ouais
bien sûr
comme un symbole du sud de la californie d'
accord
c'est à peu près juste environ 33 vous vous arrêtez d'
nous allons juste  aller à 33 20 donc ce sera un
coup de feu de deux minutes d'accord
merci de
rien
allez-vous bien alors oui reposez-vous
simplement sur ses nerfs d'acier
je voulais juste vous
remercier oh merci de m'avoir piraté
non merci d'accord vous  peut arrêter d'accord,
allons-y
peut-être qu'ils sont rentrés à la maison
oh
donc
vous pouvez vous arrêter à 35 ans d'accord
et ensuite nous ferons la maison à côté
ouais d'
accord ouais faire une pause
c'est fou
ou peut-être que ce sont des gens qui laissent tomber des lettres ou
vous savez parce qu'elle elle
elle l'a fait '  je ne l'enlève pas même si
elle a mis des trucs dedans elle espérait je suppose que
je parie que les voisins donnent des cartes et des
trucs
probablement bons
c'est intéressant
oh elle va commencer à pleurer
c'est bien ouais elle joue juste pour
la caméra elle est très bien aussi
j'aurais peut-être
parlé  p  images
pour l'assurance
ouais
ne regarde pas la caméra
elle appelle une photo du téléphone
ouais
cadre d'accord s'il te plait ouais s'il te plait sors
du thème les
machines sont libérées
c'est 27 949
de la maison
oh ouais
bon
étranger
euh de
quoi vous parlez les gars
rien de très important
nous vous ferons savoir d'
accord
je prends juste quatre crimes
il regarde les bandes
on peut arrêter ça à 39 ok
on va avoir on est
oh
à droite de l'avion
ce mec il met de l'eau sur son
voiture il tue sa voiture est-il ouais tu
vois le désordre avec ça sur la droite je
ne peux pas le voir
il est hors de mon cadre
il y avait un article en fait dans le los
angeles times ce matin les gens
n'avaient plus d'eau pour se laver  eux-mêmes
eh bien c'était ça et puis il y en avait
un autre à propos de ça qui blessait la finition de votre voiture
donc c'est sérieux
ça raconte l'histoire
41 alors tu fais le gars d'accord
c'est productif
ouais répandre l'eau à bon escient ouais
c'est de la mauvaise eau de toute façon
tu as juste besoin de t'abstenir d'accord  y sur la
droite il suffit de le faire glisser vers la droite
ouais
juste un peu le
voir oh ouais d'
accord il y a la piscine
oh ouais
je dirige un bateau propre ici
dis bonjour